[Musique]
nous sommes le peuple sans tradition nous
sommes le peuple sans pays
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] il
leur restait cette piste instrumentale
et il n'y avait pas de voix
qui correspondait là quelque chose s'est mal passé en l'
associant à quelque chose d'autre où j'ai
changé  des choses mais j'ai adoré la
piste instrumentale et j'ai une petite
maison dans un quartier funky de Miami où mon
courrier arrive et j'ai comme vous le savez des
guitares et des chants là-bas peindre des choses
comme ça et dans le courrier est venu un livre
de l'archive de lecture Ola le  la première
chose que j'ai vue et j'ai ouvert sur la première
page bang
il y avait ce poème et je pensais savoir
ce qu'il disait et je pensais que c'était
aujourd'hui dans l'Amérique de Trump le plan a été
écrit au début des années 70 et 70
vraiment pertinent aujourd'hui absolument
pertinent aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'observations là-dedans vous
savez même la ligne d'ouverture nous sommes le
peuple sans rire parce que dans chacun
de nos pays respectifs il y a des
gens qui possèdent une énorme quantité de
terres moi aussi  o pense que cette
phrase d'ouverture unique signifie également qu'au fur et à mesure qu'il
parcourt le poème, il est évident que nous
sommes des gens sans terre, soit
sans terre à nous,
vous avez mentionné Trump ou était-ce comme une
déclaration politique pour
YouTube.  pas besoin de faire une déclaration
parce que le poème est une déclaration et c'est une
déclaration inquiète et même il y a une
déclaration dans le poème et c'est tout si
je crois et si c'est le cas, ce serait
la déclaration de Louie bien que je pense que
si quelqu'un lui avait posé des questions à ce sujet  il
dirait non je décris c'est je
suppose que c'est juste une très bonne description
et peut-être qu'il y a une condamnation ce
n'est pas agréable ce n'est pas
élogieux il c'est sûr que le gars
était un tu sais un héros pour moi
artistiquement c'était quelqu'un que j'admirais  et admiré
en raison de ses compétences en tant qu'auteur
-compositeur et de ce qu'il a pu faire passer et un
parolier deux choses distinctes et ce qu'il
a pu faire passer dans ses chansons et
aussi les vibrations et la musique
nous avons tous passé dans nos
vies respectives un total peut-être de dix
heures ensemble Je lui ai rendu visite une fois dans son
appartement et je suis resté une heure pour
discuter pendant un certain temps pris trop de valium
toi